>>> THIS MORNING CNN LEARNED
SEVERAL UKRAINIANSAVE IN FACT
SURVIVED AER A THEATRE THEY
WERE SHELTERING IN WAS SLAMMED
BY HEAVY SHELLING.
YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S LEFT OF IT
THERE.
RIGHT NOW, THE HEAD OF THE
REGION TO THE NORTHEAST OF KYIV
SAYS THAT CITY IS, QUOTE,
SUFFERING GREAT LOSSES.
>> JOINING US NOW, SOMEONE WHO
IS SEEING THOSE LOSSES
FIRSTHAND.
SHE IS TATA MAHARION IN THE
CAPITAL OF KYIV.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK.
WHEN WE SPOKE WHILE I WAS IN
UKRAINE, YOU DESCRIBED JUST
HORRIFIC SCENES.
YOU DESCRIBED SEEING DEAD
CHILDREN.
THE VICTIMS OF THIS WAR.
I WONDER WHAT YOU'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST WEEK AND A HALF OR SO.
HAVE THINGS GOTTEN WORSE?
>> YEAH.
MOST DEFINITELY.
IT'S NOT LESS HEARTBREAKING TO
SEE ADULTS DIE AS WELL.
A LOT MORE CHILDREN, IF I MAY
SAY SO, JUST A COUPLE OF DAYS
AGO, WE ACTUALLY, WE WERE
LOOKING FOR A KID WHO LOST HER
LIMB BECAUSE SHE WAS SHOCKED.
WE ADMINISTERED FIRST AID AND
THEN GOT LOST AND LOOKING FOR
HER.
THAT WAS A PRETTY HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCE, I WOULD SAY, AND
THEN A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH BRAIN
DAMAGES BECAUSE AS A RESULT OF
AVIATION SHELLING, CITIES, MANY
PEOPLE ARE WOUNDED, MANY PEOPLE
ARE DYING.
AND YEAH, I'M NOT SURE IF I CAN
SAY THIS, I'M PRETTY HAPPY WE'RE
NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO IS
SUFFERING.
THE RUSSIANS ARE SUFFERING AS
WELL, BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
SO THE WAR IS ON OUR TERRITORY
BUT THE RUSSIANS ARE FEELING IT
AS WELL.
SO THIS IS WHAT KEEPS ME GOING,
PROBABLY, HELPING MY COUNTRY,
KNOWING THAT SOMETHING IS BEING
DONE.
>> THERE'S BEEN SUFFICH A FOCUS
THE STRENGTH OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE SEEN.
THE SCENE THAT YOU DESCRIBE
THOUGH, AND WHAT YOU ARE
WITNESSING ON A DAILY BASIS IN
TERMS OF THESE PHYSICAL
INJURIES, THAT HAS AN INTENSE
EMOTIONAL TOLL AS WELL.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE SHOCK AND
THAT LITTLE GIRL YOU WERE TRYING
TO HELP.
HOW DO YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE
HOLDING UP?
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP WHEN YOU
ARE FACING THIS DAY IN, DAY OUT
WITH NO CLEAR END IN SIGHT?
>> IT'S REALLY DEVASTATING WHEN
THE RUSSIANS KILL CIVILIANS AND
THEY KILL PRETTY MUCH, WELL,
THEY SPARE NOBODY.
JOURNALISTS, MEDICAL SERVICE
MEMBERS AND KIDS, THE ELDERLY
PEOPLE.
EVERYONE.
IT'S, YOU HAVE THE FEELING THAT
YOU HAVE NOWHERE TO HIDE,
PROBABLY.
AND YOU HAVE NOWHERE TO RUN,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE DRONES ARE
RIGHT ABOVE YOUR HEAD.
AND YOU ALWAYS QUESTION WHETHER
THIS IS THE DRONE OF OUR EARLY
OR THIS IS HOSTILE DRONE AND IF
IT IS, WE'RE TO HIDE.
SOMETIMES YOU DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU JUST GO WITH WHAT YOU HAVE
TO DO AND THEN THE TIMES THAT I
GET TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
ON, IT'S RIGHT BEFORE SLEEP AND
I TRY NOT TO BECAUSE I NOTICE
THAT I GET DEMORALIZED DAY AFTER
DAY.
I TRY TO STAY STRONG.
I SEE ALL THE MESSAGES, ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT MY FRIENDS FROM
ABROAD EXPRESS AND I'M VERY,
VERY THANKFUL, BUT I REALLY CAN
GO, I DON'T KNOW HOW LONGER I
CAN GO WITH NEWS OF MY FRIENDS
AND CLOSE ONES BEING CAPTURED BY
RUSSIANS BEING WOUNDED AND DYING
AND IT IS VERY, VERY DEVASTATING
AND I ALSO CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY I HAVE TO
SPEND ON THERAPY ONCE THIS ALL
ENDS, I'M SORRY FOR LAUGHING,
THIS IS A SILLY THOUGHT THAT I
HAVE.
>> LISTEN, ANY WAY TO GET
THROUGH.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE HERE
TO SPEAK TO RUSSIANS, TO PEOPLE
IF AT HOME, NOT TO PUTIN, BUT TO
RUSSIANS WHO MIGHT NOT KNOW WHAT
THE REALITY IN UKRAINE TODAY, AS
THE ARMY INVADES AND THE AIR
FORCE DROPS BOMBS.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> THIS IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
I TRY NOT TO HAVE HATRED IN MY
HEART TOWARDS ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD AND ESPECIALLY IN
RUSSIA BECAUSE I DO REALIZE
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO BE IN THE SITUATION OR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT AWARE, I DO
HAVE VERY, VERY LITTLE TOLERANCE
TOWARDS THEM BECAUSE IT'S
UNFORGIVABLE TO NOT BE AWARE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN UKRAINE RIGHT
NOW.
THE IGNORANT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CRIMES, I THINK, THERE
ARE.
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS JUST
GOOGLE WHAT IS GOING ON.
LOOK AT THE PICTURES.
THERE'S NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO,
BEING A RUSSIAN CITIZEN BECAUSE
OF THE REGIME THAT YOU HAVE, BUT
YOU CAN STRIKE, YOU CAN GO ON
DEMONSTRATIONS, YOU CAN EXPRESS
YOUR SOLIDARITY WITH UKRAINE AND
ME COMING FROM A LOST SOCIETY,
BEING A LONG TIME, I SEE MORE
TENDS TO DISQUALIFY RUSSIAN
TEAMS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
RUSSIAN TEAMS TEND TO STEP DOWN
THEMSELVES TO SHOW SOLIDARITY
WITH UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
THESE ARE THE ACTIONS THAT DO
BRING THE RUSSIANS CLOSER TO THE
REALITY AND I AM THANKFUL TO
THOSE WHO EXPRESS THEIR
POSITION, ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE SILENT.
>> MORE PEOPLE WATCHING NOW,
BECAUSE I AM IN AWE OF THE
STRENGTH AND THE SERVICE YOU'RE
SHOWING IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF
THIS.
>> THANK YOU.
THIS DOES HELP A LOT TO KNOW
THAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
>> THANK YOU, BE SAF